good copper corrupt cop I don't know it  depends on the context don't get  technical so then come up with the  content all right I'ma [ __ ] tell you  something  okay all right  I'm gonna take these [ __ ] to  the car I'll be back you see the room  full of cash like this oh cash okay cash  um and your mother needs surgery oh  absolutely  you made it that's easy  that's different you better get your  mama some titties  that's all she ever wanted a little bit  of extra just in case it's a botched job  right right yeah yeah yeah would you  take the cash because I could probably  do some good with it like better better  than boot drop your mom absolutely  problem solved